the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I'm going to continue the idea of
setting up integrals and what we'll deal
with is volumes by slices by slicing
and it's lucky that this is after lunch
maybe it's after breakfast for some of
you because there's a typical way of
introducing this subject is with a food
analogy there's a lot of ways of slicing
up food and we'll give a few more
examples in just this one but suppose
you have well suppose you have a loaf of
bread here so here's our loaf of bread
and I hope that looks a little bit like
a loaf of bread it's supposed to be
sitting on the on the kitchen counter
ready to be eaten and in order to figure
out how much bread there is there one
way of doing it is to cut it into slices
now you probably know that bread is
often sliced like this there are even
machines to do it and with this setup
here I'll draw the slice with a little
bit of a more colorful decoration so
here's our red slice of bread it's
coming around like this
and it comes back down behind all right
so here's our bread slice and and what
I'd like to figure out is its volume so
first of all there's the thickness of
the bread which is this dimension of the
thickness is this dimension DX here
and the only other dimension that I'm
going to give because this is a very
qualitative analysis for now is the what
I'll call the area and that's the area
of the face of the slice and so the area
of one slice which I'll denote by Delta
V that's a chunk of volume is
approximately the area times the change
in X and in the limit that's going to be
something like this and maybe the areas
of the slices vary there might be a
little hole in the middle of the bread
somewhere maybe it gets a little small
on one side so it might chair change as
X changes then the whole volume you get
by adding up so if you like this is one
slice and this is the sum and you should
think of it in a sort of intuitive way
as being analogous to the Riemann sum
where you would take each slice
individually and that would look like
this all right so that's just a a
superficial and intuitive way of looking
at it now we're only going to talk about
one kind of systematic slices already on
your problem set you had an example of a
slice of some region but we're only
going to talk systematically about
something called solids of revolution
the idea here is this suppose you have
some shape some graph which is maybe
looks like this and now I'm going to
revolve it this is the the x axis and
this is the y axis in this case I'm
going to revolve it around the x axis if
you do that then the shape that you get
is maybe like this if I can draw it a
little bit it's maybe a football all
right so that's the shape that you get
if you take this piece of disc and you
and you revolve it around if you had
made this copy underneath it still would
have been the same region so we only pay
attention to what's above the axis here
all right so that's the basic idea now
I'm going to apply the method of slices
to figure out the volume of such regions
and give you a general formula and then
apply it in a specific case I want to
take one little slice of this this
football maybe a football wouldn't work
too well maybe it should be we should go
back to a loaf of bread anyway the key
point is that you never really have to
draw a 3d picture and 3d pictures are
awful they're very hard to deal with and
it's hard to visualize with them and one
of the reasons why we're dealing with
solids of revolution is that we don't
have as many visualization problems so
we're only going to deal with this and
then you have to imagine from the the
two-dimensional cross-section what the
three-dimensional picture looks like so
we'll do a little bit of an exercise
with the three-dimensional picture but
ultimately you should be used to getting
used to drawing 2d diagrams always to
depict the three-dimensional situation
since it's much harder to draw the first
step is to consider what the slice is
over here and a
and it's going to have width DX and
we're going to consider what it looks
like over on the 3d picture so it's it
starts out being more or less like this
but then we're going to sweep it around
we're revolving around the x axis so
it's spinning around this way and if you
take this and think of it as being on a
hinge which is down on the x axis it's
going to swing down and swoop around and
come back swing around and that traces
out something over here which I'm going
to draw this way it traces out a disc
all right so it's hard for me to draw
and I'm not going to try too hard
maybe I drop and drew it more like a
wheel looking like a wheel but anyway
it's this little flat disc here and so
the method that I'm describing for
figuring out the volume is called the
method of disks this is going to be our
first method now I'm going to apply the
reasoning that I have up on the previous
blackboard here namely
I need to get the volume of this chunk
and the way I'm going to get the volume
of this chunk is by figuring out its
thickness and its areas cross-sectional
area and that's not too difficult to do
if this height so this height is what we
usually call Y y is usually a function
of X it's varying in this particular
distance is y then the area of the face
is easy to calculate because it's a
circle or a disk if you like with this
radius so it's area is PI Y squared so
that's if you like the one of the
dimensions and then the thickness is DX
so the incremental volume is this so
this is the method of disks and this is
the integrand
now there's one peculiar thing about
this formula and there more you learn
things about this morning but there's
one peculiar thing that you should
notice immediately which is that I'm
integrating with respect to X and I
haven't yet told you what Y is oh that
will depend on what function y equals f
of X I use so we have to plug that in
eventually if we're actually going to
calculate something we're going to have
to figure that out there's another very
important point which is that in order
to get a definite integral something I
haven't mentioned we're going to have to
figure out where we're starting and
where we're ending the picture which is
something we dealt with last time in 2d
pictures all right so let's let's deal
with an example and we'll switch over
from a football to a soccer ball I'm
going to take a circle and we'll say it
has radius a so this is zero and this is
a and I'm putting it in this particular
spot for a reason you can do this in
lots of different ways but I'm picking
this one to make certain exercise that
on your homework easier for you because
I'm doing half of it for you right now
all right yeah appreciate it yeah I'm
sure especially today it's appreciated
so again the formula has to do with
keeping track of these slices here and
we're sweeping things around so the full
region that we're talking about is the
volume of the ball of radius
okay that's what our goal is to figure
out what the volume of the ball of
radius a is all right again as I say the
thing sweeps around coming out of the
blackboard spinning around on this on
this x-axis alright so the set up is the
following it's always the same here's
our formula and we need to figure out
what's going on with that formula and so
we need to solve for y as a function of
X and in order to do that what we're
going to do is just write down the
equation for the circle this is the
circle it's centered at a zero so that's
its formula and now there's one nice
thing which is that we really didn't
need to find the formula for Y we only
needed to find the formula for y squared
so let's just solve for y squared and we
won't have to solve a quadratic or
anything take a square root that's nice
this is a squared minus x squared minus
2a X plus a squared the a Squared's
cancel these two terms cancel and so the
formula here is to ax minus x squared
all right now that is what's known as
the integrand well except for this
factor of Pi here and so the answer for
the volume is going to be the integral
of pi times this integrand to ax minus x
squared DX and that's just the same
thing as this
but now there's also the issue of the
limits which is a completely separate
problem which we also have to solve the
range of X is from this leftmost point
to the rightmost point so X varies
starts at zero and it goes all the way
up to what what's the top value here to
a and so now I have a completely
specified integral again and this was
the theme last time the whole goal is to
get ourselves to a complete formula for
something with an integrand and limits
and then we'll be able to calculate now
we've clear sailing to the end of the
problem
all right so let's just finish it off we
have the volume is if I take the
antiderivative of that that's pi times
ax squared whose derivative is 2x minus
X cubed over 3 that's the thing whose
derivative is minus x squared evaluated
at 0 and 2a and that is equal to PI
times let's see 2 squared is 4 so this
is 4 a cubed minus 8 a cubed 9 over 3
right and so all told that is let's see
12 thirds minus 8/3 by a cubed which is
a neighbor familiar formula 4/3 PI a
cubed so it worked we got it we got it
right let me just point out a couple of
other things about this formula the
first one is that from this point of
view we've actually accomplished more
than just finding the volume of the ball
we've also found the volume of a bunch
of intermediate regions which I can draw
schematically this way if I chop this
thing and this portion is X here then
the antiderivative here this region here
which maybe I'll fill in with this
region here which I'm going to call V of
X is the volume of the portion of the
sphere volume of portion of width
Exce the ball and well the formula for
it is that it's the volume is equal to
pi ax squared minus X cubed over 3
that's it so we've got something which
is actually a lot more information for
instance if you plug in x equals a not
surprisingly and this is this is a good
idea to do because it checks that we've
actually got a correct formula here so
if you like you can call this a double
check if you check V of a this should be
the volume of a half ball that's half
way if I go over here and I only go up
to a that's exactly half of the ball
that had better be half so let's just
see V of a in this case is PI and then I
have a cubed minus a cubed over 3 and
that turns out to be pi times called
total of 2/3 a cubed which is which is
indeed half now on your problem set
which you're going to want to look at is
is this full formula here of this chunk
and what it's going to be good for is is
a real-life problem that is a problem
that really came up over the summer and
this fall at a couple of universities
near here where people were trying to
figure out of a phenomenon which is well
known namely
if you have a bunch of particles in a
you know fluid and maybe the size of
these things is a is one micron that is
the radius is one micron and then you
have a bunch of other little particles
which are a lot smaller maybe ten
nanometers then what happens is that the
particles the big particles like to hug
each other they'd like to clump together
it's very they're very nice friendly
characters so whatwhat's the explanation
for this the explanation is that
actually they are not quite as friendly
as they might seem what's really
happening is that the little guys are
shoving them around and pushing them
together and they have sharp elbows the
little ones and they're pushing them
don't don't like them to be around and
and they're pushing them together but
there's actually another possibility
which is that they also will stick to
the sides of the container all right so
so there are two things that actually
happen here and if you want to get a
quantitative handle on how much of this
happens it has to do with how much space
these things take up and so the issue is
some kind of overlap between a band
around one sphere and a band around the
other sphere and this overlap region is
what you have to calculate you have to
calculate what's in here and you can do
that using this this formula here it's
not even difficult all right so this is
this is if you just cut it in half turns
out to be two of these guys and then
you're you're on your way to figuring
out this problem and the question is
which do they prefer do they prefer to
touch each other or do they prefer to
touch the wall do they all cluster to
the wall
you can actually see this in solutions
what they do and the question is to what
extent do they prefer one configuration
to the other all right so that's a real
live problem which really comes up and
came up just this year and frequently
comes up and which is solved by our
first calculation okay so now I have I
called this method one for solids of
revolution which is called the method of
disks and now I need to tell you about
the other standard method which is
called the method of shells all right so
this is this is our second method I'm
going to illustrate this one with a
holiday-themed example here this is
supposed to be a witch's cauldron whoops
which witches well well maybe more than
one which will will have this cauldron
here all right so here's this shape and
we're going to figure out how much how
much liquid is in here
I'm going to plot this maybe I'll put
this down just a bit lower here and I'm
going to make it a parabola this is y
equals x squared and I'm going to make
the top height be y equals a alright so
here's my situation
and I want to figure out how much liquid
is in here now the reason why I
presented the problem in this form of
course is really to get you used to
these things and the first new thing
that I want you to get used to is the
idea that now we can also revolve around
the y axis not just the x axis so this
one is going to be revolved around the y
axis and that's what happens if you spin
the parabola around you get this kind of
shape this kind of solid shape here all
right now I'm going to use the same kind
of slicing that I did before but it's
going to look totally different namely
I'll draw it in red again I'm going to
take a little slice over here and now I
want to imagine what happens if it gets
revolved around the y axis
this time it's not a disc actually if I
revolve this around the other way it
would have had a hole in it which is
also possible to do that's practically
the same as the method of disks you'll
maybe discuss that in recitation anyway
we're going to revolve it around this
way so again I need to sweep it around
swing it around like this and I'll draw
the shape it's going to sweep around in
a circle and maybe it'll have a little
bit of thickness to it and this is the
thing that people call a shell right
this is the shell so called shell of the
method I would maybe call it a cylinder
and another way of thinking about it is
that you can maybe wrap up a piece of
paper and write like this there it is
there's a there's a cylinder you can see
very thin right great thin all right now
the reason why I use the piece of paper
as an example of this is that I'm going
to have to figure out the volume of this
thing its thickness as usual is equal to
DX its height is what well actually I
have to use the diagram to see that the
top value is a and the bottom value is
what we call Y so the height is equal to
I'm sorry
a minus lot now again this is an
incredibly risky thing here and I've
done this before I pointed this out on
the very first day of lecture the letter
Y represents a lot of different things
in disguise when I call this why I mean
y is equal to x squared in other words
the interesting curve I don't mean y
equals a which is the other part in
general you might think of it as being
equal to Y top minus y bottom so there
of course two y's involved in disguise
but we have a shorthand and the sort of
uninteresting one we call bias we just
evaluate immediately in the interesting
one we leave as a symbol y alright now
the last bit that I have to do I claim
in order to figure this out is the
circumference and the reason for that is
that if I think of this thing as like
this tube or piece of paper here in
order to figure out how much stuff there
is here all I have to do is unfold it
its its size it's the whole quantity of
paper here is the same whether it's
rolled up like this or whether it's
stretched out so if I unwrap it it looks
like what well it looks like it's kind
of a slab right it looks like just a
slab like this and again the thickness
is DX the height is a minus y and now we
can see that the length here is all the
way around
it's the circumference all right so this
is going to be the circumference when I
unwrap it and in order to figure out the
circumference I need to figure out the
radius so the radius is on this diagram
is right over there
this is the radius and that distance is
X
so this length here is X and so this
circumference is 2 pi X and this height
is is still a Y a - y sorry and the
thickness is still is still DX right all
right so in total we're just going to
multiply these numbers together to get
the total volume we have in other words
DV is equal to the product of the two PI
X dimension the 8th - Y dimension and
the DX solution incidentally dimensional
analysis is very useful and important in
these problems you can see that there
are three lengths being multiplied
together so we'll get a volume in the
end something cubic and we will be
coming back to that because it's a quite
subtle issue sometimes all right so
here's the formula and let's simplify it
a little bit we have 2 pi x times
remember first I have to substitute
otherwise I'm never going to be able to
integrate and then I rewrite that as 2
pi ax minus x squared
whoops X cubed x better not get that
wrong and now the last little bit here
that I had better be careful about in
order to figure out what the total
volume is is the limits so the volume is
going to be the integral of this
quantity 2 pi ax minus X cubed DX
and now I have to pay attention to what
the limits are
now here you have to be careful X is
possibly the the you have to go always
go back to the the 2d diagram I went to
it immediately but that's that's the
whole point is that everything gets read
off from this diagram here when you take
this guy and you sweep it around you
take care of everything that's to the
left so we only have to count what's to
the right we don't have to count
anything over here because it's taken
care of
when we sweep around so the starting
place is going to be x equals 0 that's
where we start and where we end is the
farthest rightmost spot for X which is
down here and you got to watch out about
where that is in the Y variable it's up
at y equals a but in the X variable we
can see that it's what it's the square
root of ay all right so these these
limits this is where you're going to
you're going to focus all your attention
on the integrand and getting it just
right and then you're going to lose your
steam and not pay attention to the
limits they're equally important you've
no hope of getting the right answer
without getting a limits right all right
so this is the integral from 0 to square
root of ay again that's just because y
equals a and y equals x squared implies
x equals square root a that's that upper
limit there and now we're ready to carry
out this to evaluate this integral so we
get to uh sorry we get to pie ax that's
pi ax squared now maybe I'll leave it
the twos in there two pi ax squared is
the antiderivative of this x squared
over two and then here X to the fourth 4
evaluated at zero and square root of a
and finally let's see what is that
that's 2pi times a squared over two
minus a squared over 4 which is a total
of a fourth right 2pi times a squared
over four which is PI over 2 pi squared
yes question right so the question is
why did I integrate only from the middle
to this end instead of all the way from
over here minus square root of a all the
way to the plus end and the reason is
that you have to you have to look at
what's happening with the rotation this
red guy when I swept it around I counted
the stuff to the right and the left so
in other words eyeball if if I just
rotate the right half of this uncovering
the left half so if I did it if I
counted the stuff from minus square root
of eight I would be doing it twice I
would be doubling what I need right so
it's too much another way of saying it
is if if I wanted to take the whole
region if I rotate it around only 180
degrees only pi that would fill up the
whole region if I did both halves and
then instead of a circumference instead
of a two pi X I would could use a PI X
but then and I would have double what I
had so that there are two ways of
looking at it the same goes actually for
the football case when I have that
football I didn't count the bottom part
because when I swung it around the x
axis the top part sufficed and I could
ignore the bottom half yeah another
question
oh good question the question is when do
you know what how do you know when to
take the rectangle to be vertical or
horizontal so far we've only done
vertical rectangles and I'm going to do
a horizontal example in a second and the
answer to the question of when you do it
is this you can always set it up both
ways one way maybe a difficult
calculation and one maybe one way maybe
an easier calculation yesterday we did
it or sorry the last time yeah I guess
it was yesterday we did it with width
and the horizontal in the vertical were
quite different in character one of them
was really a mess and one of them was a
little easier so very often one will be
easier than the other every once in a
while one of them is impossible and the
other one is possible in other words the
difference in difficulty can be extreme
so you don't know that in advance yeah
another question the question is did we
just find the volume when you when you
rotate this green region around or did
we find the volume when we rotate this
whole region in other words just the
right half or the let or the right and
the left half the answer is both the
region that you get is the same you
always get this cauldron whether you
take this right half and you rotate it
around or you take both and you rotate
it around okay so the answer to both of
those questions is the same and it's
this yeah
it's so that if you rotated them both
around and you only wanted to cover
things once you would rotate halfway
around if you only by 180 degrees that's
true but you can rotate around as many
times as you want you're still covering
the same thing over and over and over
and over again okay
okay so let's let's go on I have a very
subtle point that I need to discuss with
you in order to go on to the next
application here so so here's my and I
do want to get to the point of
horizontal cross sections as well so
let's let's continue here so the first
thing that I want to point out to you
now is I want you to beware of units
there's something a little fishy in this
problem and it can be summarized in the
character of the answer which is just a
little bit not clear namely it looks
like it's a squared right and we know
that a is in units and we should have
gotten cubic units so there's something
a little bit tricky about this question
and so I want to illustrate the paradox
right now so suppose that a is a hundred
centimeters and suppose the units are
centimeters then the formula for the
volume is PI over 2 times 100 squared
and the units we must take our
centimeters cubed
despite the fact that you kind of want
to square the centimeters but that's not
what this problem says okay so this is
the situation that we we've got now if
you work out what this is
to figure out what the volume of this
cauldron is what you find is that it's
PI over 2 times well 10 to the fourth
power is 10 times a thousand centimeters
cubed right and those are otherwise
known as leaders so this is
approximately 10 PI over 2 liters which
is about 16 liters and so that's how
much was in the cauldron under this
choice of units now I'm going to make
another choice of units now and we're
going to make comparison suppose that
the units are 1 meter looks like it
should be the same but if I calculate
the volume it's going to be PI over 2 +
1 squared times meters cubed right
that's what the formula tells us to do
and if you calculate that out that's PI
over 2 times a hundred centimeters cubed
and with this unit notation we really do
want to cube the centimeters in cubes
100 so we get PI over 2 and here we get
10 to the sixth centimeters cubed and
that comes out to PI over 2 times a
thousand liters or in other words about
1600 liters so I'd like to ask you first
to contemplate this and this is a
paradox and this is a serious paradox if
you really want to apply problems you
actually have to understand what your
answers need so what do you think is
going on here yeah
yes right so the question is how could
either of these make sense how am i
dealing with the units in either case
all right so now I'm going to explain to
you the answer because this is really
quite puzzling but it has a resolution
the answer to this question is that both
answers are correct all right this is
correct reasoning in both cases
what's the matter is that you have to
interpret the equation y equals x
squared in two different ways two ways
so let me explain what they are for
instance you can take y equals x squared
with in centimeters so y equals x
squared in centimeters in which case the
picture looks like the following a is
equal to 100 centimeters and this
distance here which is the this is the
this is the x value this is 10 all right
this is 10 centimeters and that's what
the relationship means so the top of the
cauldron if you like this distance here
is 20 centimeters this is actually very
badly drawn to scale it's actually very
very deep this thing it's a rather
skinny deep one okay so this is very
much not to scale this picture
the other picture the other picture is
interpreting y equals x squared and
meters and that's more like what I had
in mind actually I had in mind this big
vat here and this distance here is is 1
meter and then the square root of 1 is 1
so this distance here is also 1 meter
and the top is 2 meters right now it's
not that crazy
and in fact it's easy to check that it's
pretty reasonable in terms of scale that
this thing has 16 liters in it and this
guy has 1600 liters in it all right so
you actually have to know what your
symbols mean when you're dealing with
these kinds of applied problems and if
you're ever really going to do some some
real consequences you have to know what
what it is that what the unit's mean and
the problem with the equation y equals x
squared is it it's the one that violated
scaling rules yeah
ya know
okay so the question is whether the
formula V equals 1/2 sorry pi over 2a
squared this is the correct answer to
the problem but it is not consistent in
units if you plug in a equals some
number of centimeters some number of
millimeters some number of inches and so
on every single time you'll get a
different answer and they're all
inconsistent in other words this formula
violates scaling if you interpret if you
make if you look if you study each step
correctly you will discover that these
are the consistent and correct
statements when I'm writing on the
blackboard and this makes sense in a
unitless sense but then if you actually
stick units on them you one of them they
both are correct and one of them
describes this situation and one of them
describes this situation and it's a
mistake to think of this as being one
meter in cubing the meters all right
that's that will be an error that will
that will cause you problems all right
this one is just unitless and then the
meters cube got converted alright so I
encourage you to study this on your own
so now I'm going to I'm going to
introduce the next problem we'll have to
solve it next time but the reason why I
spend all the time on units is that
otherwise it would be impossible for you
to believe me when I do this next
calculation all right because we're
trying to get a real answer out of a
real question and I'm going to make
conversions between centimeters and
meters back and forth and we have to get
it consistent in order to have the right
answer so there was a reason for for
illustrating this pitfall so the second
the next thing that I like to do is I'd
like to I'd like to boil the water in
the in the witch's cauldron all right
this is definitely seasonally
appropriate since we're approaching
Halloween and we'll work it out fully
next time now I'm going to introduce
another feature into the problem and
this is the one that I want you to
understand now we'll set it all up
tomorrow but right now I need you to
understand what the new main idea that
we're going to we're going to get ok
there's the new physical feature that
I'm going to add to this problem is that
if when you're boiling when the witches
are boiling this this water the
temperature of the water is not the same
at each level in the kettle at the
bottom of the kettle where you're
heating it up it's at its highest
temperature so at the bottom it's going
to be say a hundred degrees that is it's
going to be totally boiling 100 degrees
Celsius and at the top it's going to be
say 70 degrees
right it's very cold outside in fact
it's zero degrees outside which is the
the temperature which all which is
operate I think anyway so so so they're
boiling their their their their stuff
and the question that we're going to ask
is how much heat how much heat do they
need to do it now they don't the thing
starts out at zero degrees Celsius and
we're going to heat it up to this
temperature configuration here but it's
it's rising from a hundred down here at
a seventy up here so the the temperature
is varying in height and I for
simplicity I'm going to make the formula
for the temperature be 100 at the top
and 70 at the BA sorry seventy at the
bar top and 100 at the bottom so it's
going to be a hundred minus 30y well
we'll let the level be b1 here sorry
thirty I said three I wrote three but I
meant thirty all right so this is the
situation that we have now it's the the
point about this problem is we're going
to figure out the total temperature that
the total amount of heat that you need
to add in order to heat this thing up
that's going to be temperature times
volume to nth but some places will count
more than others these will be hotter
but there's less water down here there's
this is wider up here so there's more
water up here so there are various
things that are varying in this problem
now the only way to set it up so that it
works is to chop things up horizontally
instead of vertically because it's on
the horizontal levels that the
temperature is constant so we'll have an
easy calculation for how much it takes
to heat up a layer a horizontal layer
when we rotate this guy around the
y-axis that is which kind of shape
it's a disk so it actually this one's
going to be an easier problem it's going
to be a disk problem not a shell problem
but we're going to have to work things
out with respect to the dy variation in
other words the integral will be deep
with respect to dy so we will do that
next time we'll figure out how much heat
it takes to boil the kettle